When the pandemic hit,...
...businesses anticipated that the COVID recession was coming.
They thought that demand was going to drop.
But something funny happened.
The opposite of what all of these businesses...
...and economists predicted happened.
Demand exploded.
People bought things like crazy,...
...and now supply chains are choking on that record demand.
Everyone has had the experience of not being able to get something,...
...and everyone has had the experience of paying more for something.
Prior to the pandemic, most of us just took it for granted that...
...we could get things ever faster.
E-commerce made it seem like everything was right at our doorstep,...
...but that obscures what was a 14,000-mile journey halfway around the world.
It took months.
And when you add up all the automation, all the algorithms,...
...all of the hundreds of people who had to touch those goods...
...or transport them in some way,...
...it's in total, one of the most complicated endeavors...
...that human beings ever engage in,...
...and yet, it happens millions of times per day...
...and we take it for granted...
....because all of that has been rolled...
...behind this ultimate convenience of just one click e-commerce shopping.
But the pandemic showed us just how unsustainable...
...and unrealistic that expectation is.